ce qu'ils écoutent aujourd'hui on va
jouer à deux simulateurs incroyable
surtout le premier parce qu'on va
pouvoir jouer ben oui bypass tu vas
pouvoir je veux mon héros préférés de
tous les temps incontrôlable robote
voilà on joue iron man iron man à la
retraite après la mort même et le but
c'est juste de ramasser des petites
statuettes
bah voilà à les jeux suivants bon bah
quand même jouer un petit peu en
pillages sweeting de ouf
si herman se déplacer que c'était bon
nul à temps mais je peux me relis pas
oui c'est bon je sais à temps ok c'est
reparti cette fois c'est bon je sais on
est déjà sur le dos mais c'est l'autre
qui arrive faut faire quoi
faucheux la faire tomber dedans est-ce
qu'on peut juste [ __ ] hop là ok c'est
ça faut juste les faire tomber
alors maintenant on va devoir voler
c'est sa came tu me relèverai bats on y
aime pas de soi un ronald vraiment le
budget est décédé oh non je contrôle je
contrôle je contrôle je compte aux
bateaux au mouillage suis fait pour et
iron man c'est faux c'est faux c'est mon
rêve mais ça n'arrivera jamais ben là
par contre qu'ils feraient talonnade
pour faire ça tu crois que je vais
tomber et je tombe vraiment à temps mon
gars et je vous jure que honda on n'aura
pas fini cette vidéo tant qu'ils seront
pas tous tombés dans d'affreuses
souffrances que moi je suis un petit peu
violent à autonome écoutez j'ai un peu
de mal déjà je suis troublé par ce
papier peint qui est tout simplement
scandaleux un pied un papier peint avec
des taxis dessus personne à limiter
hubert méo le conflit des ouf
oh là là le mec il embrouille et où le
clash non mais c'est pas possible mon
gars je suis archi nul la hausse entre
les deux mais c'est une boutade c'est
une grosse blague et voilà voilà jean
michel courau ok je stabilise
c'est parti est déjà a déjà son souviens
bien har homa dans ses premiers épisodes
il fait par action avec la vraie armure
oh t'as rien vu venir bata c'est pour
toi mais résiste lui c'est le colonel
aurait le but est ici attend pas on va
faire ça par l'arrière vous allez voir
ça va être très sale aéro bad tu ta
hockey onel colonel o'neill connell tous
les autres sont dans la merde
et ouais mon pote on va faire tomber le
carton garba bon ça soit sur toile mango
sb question à faire ou à se contrôler
regarder je pars pas du contrôle
surprise que tal lundi matin oh [ __ ]
excellent outil contrôle de la poitrine
que tu fais en foot ok on arrête d'être
comment excuser moi c'est le stress aux
tab richert arte a pris tard il fallait
pas taclé françois bâtard désolé à tous
les françois price bardaf à coeur on les
a tous eu auquel on reste plus que cinq
pompes à eau flip allez y est on s'en
bat les couilles
on perce la fenêtre on s'échappe du jeu
bien c'est du black c'est boutin c'est
debout tu as assez pour distraire les
demies et là vous allez voir que
tellement soudainement la boutin a fait
les personnels la lega va y travaillent
de chez danone et oui le petit dernier
mon gars il est comment as-tu osé faire
ça à tes amis espèce de lâche tu es un
déserteur tu a fui les combats à ses
terres au mad à vous les studios
bienvenue soyaux jour simulator un
simulateur de petites filles on va
s'éclater sépare tu as tant cette
musique faut juste la bannir à tout
jamais la planète terre on est bel et
bien sur un jeu japonais
vous allez voir on peut faire pas que
d'autres trucs dans ce jeu j'ai vu le
trailer ça avait l'air vraiment moyen
dans le sens où on peut juste sauté sur
les murs oh [ __ ] béziers mais birdie
sur dix et on peut aussi chuté sur les
gens et c'est ça qui nous intéresse
c'est excellent savage coups de pied
coups de pied bâtard apte et vole
vraiment on aurait pu shooter l'humain
avec l'autre humains attendait allez
allez non on a raté à temps au nom je
suis dit que ça serait passé ma vie
c'est de la merde
regardez voici cuisses de grenouilles
[ __ ] j'ai les mêmes déjà j'aimerais
bien monter sur un toit
c'était possible à l'aide de cette
chaise bien la jeune d'accord la chaise
monte sur le toit avant moi oh oh oh le
bug au [ __ ] j'avais trouvé un glitch
monga abandonné attendait la bayard
chemin
aux attendes vosges avoir là-bas obligé
fauche passé domino sur comment on fait
pour aller là-haut alors attention il
faut un diplôme d'ingénieur pour
comprendre cette part-là par la part
l'attend on a les palettes mondiale sont
pas là pour rien elles elles sont là
pour disparaître au détour innova
regardez pas besoin d'aller sur un toit
caisse convalescent merdé sur un toit
juste à faire ça on s'amuse beaucoup
dans ce jour
oh oh oh [ __ ] ça y est ça y est
première étape de fait pitaro bien
regardez les c'est tellement bon soir
les phocéens parent et d'un coup de pied
elle c'est trop marrant les mecs ils
s'envolent et sous je me tape trop débat
nous sommes maintenant sur be cyclisme
l'art de faire du vélo alors les
contrôles c'est un peu comme coupe voyez
faut pédaler et je comprends rien
fallait pas tourner mec
comment on tourne mais pourrait bien
agressé mais casse noix attend il ya
trop de casse à moi je suis radin moi je
repars prend des pièces au revoir et
bien des palois qui vous attaquent quoi
c'est n'importe quoi
mais chassez monputeaux.com l'abus total
je vais finir cette piste en cours mais
[ __ ] pas de magasin d'entrée de jeu
quoi pourquoi moi mon gars je crois
qu'un saut ya un soupirail un sens où
c'est génial ça c'est sûr de pédaler
c'est bon on l'a fait on l'a fait on est
premier on est en tête à attends je suis
carrément a dit de faire ce jeu voilà je
préfére est un vélo 4 iron man of steel
au ce style manga sa saga permis vélo ça
cette fois je vous dis non mais oh non
mais je vous le dis vous tient chaque
fois je vous dis mais c'est faux là
c'est vrai cette fois c'est la bonne
voilà on a pris toutes les pièces en
plus pour bien dégager [ __ ] pourquoi
ils vont bientôt
non mais c'est pas possible je vais
finir la course entre les pingouins et
les plots un jour un os il s'est plaint
à un coude sa part ils sont au programme
sert à tanger en train de rire sur des
vélos virtuel qui se prêtent des kodak l
homo m'aviez bien regardez là c'est bien
là c'est bien ouais les pins comme pas
tous les départs de plus roulettes on a
pleuré tous les grands écrans m'a
demandé d'où surveille plus c'est à nous
de nous gérer tout seul ou dans la vie
adulte cette fois et on va y arriver
attention je le sens elle est au top ce
virage monga bouge où il a touché le
véto quoi un vrai motard dans l'âme il
fait quoi les gars là bas elle est
perdue
regardez le loser par contre pour des
problèmes de type tendons à je vais
devoir arrêter dans pas très longtemps
ok j'ai versé comment javert ses
commandes est-ce que ça a l'air de
marcher pas du tout en haut
on a passé où la masse il viendra genre
avec cette victoire bon gars un moment
fait l'hémicycle le fuck les tricycles
feuq les insérer un jeu de mot avec
cycle j'ai pas réussi au revoir mais ben
jazia 27,2 sur ses trois petits
simulateur c'était intense était plein
de 2
fail n'hésitez pas à mettre à dos aux
influences sont très vite dans une
prochaine du coup si j'ai envie de jouer
aujourd'hui à des petits jeux gratuits
sauf oeil aux jo qui est pas gratuit
juste une arnaque l'arnaqué gratuit tél
par contre le jeu n'ont rien compris ou
pas mais ça au regard des sauveteurs
dans une prochaine vidéo portez vous
bien sûr tout le monde
pis